-It's almost summer,
and everyone is excited
to finally go on vacation again.
-I already booked my trip.
-Oh, hey, Ally.
And a Heineken, huh?
Looks like you're
on vacation already.
-You know it, but since
you're still on the clock,
I got you a can
of Heineken 0.0.
Zero alcohol.
-Oh! Well, thank you.
Mmm. I didn't realize
it came in cans.
-Well, I'm glad it does,
'cause my friends and I rented
a pontoon boat for our vacation
to the lake,
and you can't bring
glass bottles on the boat.
-A pontoon boat?
That sounds fun.
-Yeah, except
we booked it for 9:00.
-A.M.?
-I know, right?
Sounds like a tee time.
-Well, better than 9:00 P.M.
-Actually, that's when
we booked our tee time.
-How? Are you playing mini golf?
-Oh!
[ Fingers snap ]
Speaking of mini, we booked
a one-room cabin
for the eight of us.
-Wow. So it sounds like you guys
are a little rusty
at planning vacations.
Did you at least get
trip insurance?
-There's trip insurance?
-Have you ever been
on vacation before, Ally?
-I-I went on a cruise once.
-That's not where
I was going with that.
-Ugh. This is gonna
be a disaster, isn't it?
-You know what? Just have
a cooler of these handy,
and you'll have a good time
no matter what.
-You're right.
Lake Chernobyl, here we come!
-Yeah, how do you feel about
maybe a staycation?
Open your camera now
and scan the code
to find a can of Heineken
or Heineken 0.0 near you
to enjoy the same
light, refreshing taste
no matter what
your summer plans are.